CHRIS DIBONA: Hi, everyone.
My name is Chris DiBona.
I look after stuff here
at Google sometimes.
And one of things I look
after is open source, and also
a little bit of our
relationship with NASA,
specifically over at Ames.
And when this talk
was proposed--
and I was just
saying this to Jay--
it's almost like it's a dog
whistle that is like, OK, so
open source mission
control for Chrome.
So space, open source, Google.
So this is a really
well-suited talk.
I was wondering if he could
work Android into it somehow
or something like Kubernetes.
But anyway, the
long and short of it
is, Jay is here from Ames
to talk about his project.
JAY TRIMBLE: So, I like
to be very interactive.
If you guys have questions,
please just go ahead and ask.
If you look at that topic list--
open source, mission control,
Chrome-- any one of those
could probably be its own talk.
So I try to get enough in there
to at least seed the questions,
and we'll go from there.
I like to start with this,
because I think when people
think of NASA,
they usually think
of Cape Canaveral or maybe
Mission Control Houston.
You guys are down
the street from Ames,
so you know about us.
And of course, there's JPL.
But there's really a lot of
NASA all over the country,
so I like to start with
this, just give people
a little bit of perspective
of what the centers are
and what the
geography looks like.
So the mission control,
obviously, is for missions.
And what are we doing
with these missions?
We have a lot of discussions
about human missions.
We used to call it
manned space flight,
but we don't do that anymore.
We call it human space flight
versus robotic space flight.
And how do we experience this?
I just want as
background for this talk
to think a little
bit about that.
What is the mission experience?
If a person flies in
space and it's not you,
does that really enhance
your experience of it?
Maybe it does.
Maybe you can
vicariously enjoy that.
Versus a robot, which I think
is a little bit less personal.
On the other hand, the pictures
don't really look any different
whether they are from
a robot or a human.
And of course, robots we
can get much further out
that we can get people,
at much lower costs.
So I think there's
going to continue
to be a balance between
these mission types.
As far as mission
control goes, I just
wanted to get across the
idea of one-way light time
and round-trip light time,
because it completely
bounds and affects
how we operate.
So if you look at the
moon, round-trip light time
from the moon, that's
only a couple of seconds.
But you add the latency in for
the communications overhead,
and you're probably looking
at six seconds, maybe
10 seconds, maybe 25 seconds.
It's not long.
But if you're trying to
joystick a rover on the moon,
for example, that can
actually be a very long time.
If you're out at
Mars where you're
looking at 20 minute, 48
minute round-trip light time,
the idea of any kind of real
time command and control
just goes out the window.
So all the films you may have
seen of Apollo and the ground
control interactions
with the crew,
that all goes away at Mars.
By the time you get to Saturn
and further out, forget it.
I worked Voyager Neptune.
I think we had a four
hour one-way light time.
So by the time we
send a command,
it was eight hours before
we knew what happened.
So that really
impacts, obviously,
the design of how we do
missions and what we do where.
So for crude missions,
we really have never
gone past the moon in most
of you guys' lifetime.
And from the time
I was a little kid,
we haven't been out
of low Earth orbit.
So you really do have real
time communication there,
and you can decide how
to allocate the jobs.
So what would you think?
Do you want to do
it all in orbit?
That would be the
airplane model, right?
You look at the space shuttle,
and you think about an airplane
cockpit, and you're
doing everything onboard.
But if you look at
the space station,
a lot of the space
station is actually
flown from the ground, which
may be counter-intuitive.
But we get into
questions like, what
is the value of astronaut time?
What can we do most
effectively where?
I see somebody looking
puzzled back there.
So anyway, feel
free to interrupt me
if you have a question.
The basic things we do
in mission control--
and you guys-- have you
seen mission control on TV?
When I say "mission
control," do you
have an image in your mind
of what one of these rooms
looks like, maybe a
sense of what we do?
So a lot of it is system
health and status.
You can think of plumbers,
electricians, life support,
all the people who just
have to be the eyes
and ears of the crew,
because you've got more data,
you've got bigger screens.
Think of the space station.
I think it has
160,000 parameters.
Pretty hard for a
couple of crew members
to monitor 160,000
parameters, or even
a bunch of people on the ground.
Planning-- what are
you going to do?
You've got this incredibly
high-value time.
You've either got a crew or
you've got a robotic asset.
What am I doing with that time?
Trajectory, which is where am
I, or where am I on the surface?
And authority-- who's in charge?
Listen to a tape of
the moon landing,
and listen to
those interchanges.
And the ground could
have called an abort.
You wonder.
And then read what
the astronauts
said about what
they would have done
in some of these instances,
and it gets very interesting.
But I think one of the
things with authority
comes down to how
much you can see.
And we simply can see
more on the ground
than a crew can see, obviously--
bigger displays, more
data, more eyes and ears.
OK.
And conceptually, this is
how we do it for robots.
So my first thought
was, well, I was
going to put all
from the ground,
but then there is this
sense of autonomy.
We tend to be, I think,
stingy and conservative
when it comes to autonomy,
probably with good reason.
Because when you get an asset
up on Mars, for example,
you're just going to be
very conservative about how
you operate it,
at least at first.
So really, everything--
obviously, all the authority,
command, and control is
done from the ground.
There is no crew when you're
talking about a robot.
So this is-- did you
guys recognize this?
This is the iconic mission
control from Apollo.
I'm going to talk a little bit
about what those consoles do
versus how we do it
now in a later slide.
That's the newer version
of the same control center.
That's after Mars Science lab.
Now, why is everybody
jumping up and down here,
and nobody's jumping
up and down here?
Now, I've read
things in the media
that would lead you
to believe that it's
just because these guys over
here are boring, and staid,
and old school, and these guys
over here are modern and cool,
and they're going to celebrate,
and they're much looser,
and they're wearing polo
shirts, whereas these guys are
wearing suits and ties.
This is where I
started, by the way.
So I've been one of those
guys once upon a time,
wearing that coat and tie.
I don't actually think
that's the main reason.
I think it gets back to
my earlier slide, which
is one-way light time.
So here, you've got real
time command and control.
You are watching things.
What you do has an
immediate impact.
Here, anything
you do, you're not
going to know what
happened for 20 minutes.
You've got a little bit
more room for celebration.
And part of it
could be cultural.
I'm just saying,
technically, there
are reasons why you will see
people acting differently
in different contexts like that.
This is a science room.
I took this picture.
I think it was 2004, just before
the first Mars Exploration
Rover landing.
Incredibly exciting.
That's the engineering side for
the Mars Exploration rovers.
That's the science side.
I wanted to throw in one
from down the street.
That was for [? Laddie. ?] And
when we say "mission control--"
though I'm going to talk
a lot about this version,
because I've worked
more in there
than I have in the
others-- mission control
takes a lot of different
forms, and has been evolving,
and is going to continue
evolve how we do it.
So I wanted to have
a little bit of fun.
Because when I was a kid in
a summer intern in mission
control for the first
time, all of a sudden,
I watched a "Star Trek"
episode, and in my mind,
I started mapping who the
characters were to the mission
control positions.
So I won't tell
you which version
of "Star Trek" that was,
but I'll tell you it
wasn't any of the newer ones.
That was a while ago.
So we have a flight
director, call sign flight.
And that clearly is the captain.
And then we have
systems positions
who are responsible for
all the engineering.
That would be Mr. Scott if
you're in the old "Star Trek."
In the newer ones, I'm
going to lose my way here.
I think it was Geordi in
"The Next Generation."
I don't remember who it was for
"Voyager" or "Deep Space Nine."
You guys can help
me out with that.
And the navigation, that
was Chekov, where are we?
We have trajectory.
It's called Fido,
Flight Dynamics.
And then payloads-- and a POCC
is Payload Operations Control
Center.
That tends to be
where the science is.
We've got a lot of scientists
in back rooms doing science,
interfacing with the
flight control teams.
So that would be Spock.
That would be the
front room position.
And then InCO for the shuttle
was Integrated Communications
Officer, and that
would be Uhura.
And you guys can
help me out if you
want to get to some of
the newer "Star Treks."
I'm dating myself
here, I admit it.
So I want to just go through
a couple of calls from mission
control so you get a
better sense of how
all these positions
operate together.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-OK, all flight controllers,
going to go for landing.
Retro.
-Go.
-Fido.
-Guidance
-Go.
-Control.
-Telcom.
-Go.
-[INAUDIBLE]
-Ecom.
-Go.
-Surgeon.
-Cap Com, we are go for landing.
-Altitude 4,200.
-Houston, you are go
for landing, over.
-Roger, Houston.
Go for landing.
[END PLAYBACK]
JAY TRIMBLE: Does anybody
recognize any of those voices?
Any space historians in here?
The flight director
was Gene Kranz.
Anybody who's seen Apollo
13 probably-- yeah.
And then the Cap Com
was Charlie Duke.
And of course, that was Buzz
Aldrin in the lunar module
while Neil Armstrong was flying.
The point I want
to make here is,
that was simply a nominal
set of status calls.
You have these pre-defined
points where the flight
director is going
to give a go, no go,
and then all positions
respond, hopefully, go.
And they're very high adrenaline
and very exciting, real time.
And you can only
do that when you're
close enough to Earth for
that to be meaningful.
And by the time you get
to Mars, a call like that
will be very different.
So that was a nominal.
Let's look at an anomaly.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Bravo 1.
-[INAUDIBLE] 1201 alarm.
-1201 alarm [INAUDIBLE].
-[INAUDIBLE] we're go, flight.
-OK, we're go.
-We're go.
[INAUDIBLE], we're go.
[END PLAYBACK]
JAY TRIMBLE: To me
personally, this
is probably my favorite call
in mission control history.
I think they were
about 10,000 feet
off the surface of the moon.
I could be wrong.
And there were a series of
computer program alarms,
meaning the commuter
was just overloaded.
It was getting
information faster
than they could handle it.
But picture Neil Armstrong
flying this thing.
We've never landed
on the moon before.
10,000 feet.
I hope I'm right about that.
It could have been higher.
And these alarms are coming in.
And mission control
is looking at them,
and you're going to give a go,
no go call to land on the moon
or not for the first time ever.
You hear a go, and that's
from the front room position.
I believe that was Steve Bales,
probably DPS, data processing,
and probably three folks in
the back room backing him up.
So these guys in the
front room you see,
they have more eyes and
ears than the back room.
I believe they had trained
to some of this, thank god,
so they were able to make
that call very quickly.
To me, what a position to be in.
As a flight controller,
I'd have given anything
to be in a position to
make a call like that.
And of course,
those opportunities
just don't come
along very often.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-OK, Houston, we've
had a problem here.
-Flight guidance.
-Go, guidance.
-We've had a hardware restart.
I don't know what it was.
-Houston, we've had a problem.
We've had a main B bus interval.
-You see an AC bus
undervolt there, guidance?
Or Ecom?
-Negative, flight.
-I believe the crew reported it.
-We've got a main B undervolt.
-We may have had an
instrumentation problem,
flight.
[END PLAYBACK]
JAY TRIMBLE: So in
a case like that,
you are getting-- you are
on these little monochrome
displays-- and I'm going to
show you an example of what
these things look like-- and
you have a set of numbers,
and you know what they're
supposed to look like,
and they are going crazy
all over the place.
And the flight
controllers on the ground
have to put this puzzle together
and figure out what's going on.
It is not like
"Star Trek," where
Mr. Spock looks into his little
sensor and the light shines out
and he says, this is exactly
what's going on, Captain.
It is not like that.
And you're dealing with
engineering schematics
and sensors and trying to
piece all this puzzle together
to figure out what that means.
And on Apollo 13, that was a--
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-[INAUDIBLE]
-[INAUDIBLE] copy, stand by.
-Flight Fido, abort ATO.
-Abort ATO.
-Challenger Houston, abort ATO.
[END PLAYBACK]
JAY TRIMBLE: So a little
background on that, and then
I'm going to-- this is
the last tape I have.
Space shuttle asset, Challenger,
ATO is Abort To Orbit.
A main engine had shut down.
So three main engines, one
of them has just shut down.
Why has it shut down?
That's question number one.
What do you do about it?
So you heard the call.
Fido in there--
and I had mentioned
Fido-- that's flight dynamics.
So where are we?
What's our speed?
Where can we go?
So they had an Abort
To Orbit option
on two engines, which they took.
Turned out the
engine had shut down
because of a sensor problem.
There was actually nothing
wrong with the engine.
There was also a sensor
problem in another engine.
And if they had
lost two engines,
it would have been real trouble.
So Booster-- and I think
that was Jenny Howard-- made
what I think was a very
gutsy and exciting call
to inhibit those sensors,
meaning if something really
went wrong, you wouldn't have
had the benefit of the sensors
to shut that engine down.
So there's risk
involved in that.
She made that call.
The flight director says, main
engine, limits to inhibit,
tells the crew to do
an abort to orbit.
And they get into a lower,
but still functional, orbit,
and had a successful mission.
So those are
examples of the kinds
of things you can do in
real time mission control.
And it can be very cool stuff.
And those are highlight films.
Every day is not
a highlight film.
Sometimes, it's just the
regular day-to-day stuff.
But there are exciting moments.
So the consoles-- and you guys
are all into technology, right?
So I thought you might
find a little interesting
what all these things do.
If you ever watched
and old Apollo tape,
these lights are
always flashing.
I was this little kid
wondering what in the world
those lights were doing,
what the flashing was.
I know most of you
guys weren't born,
but I was a little
kid at the time.
OK.
So this is the old mission
control, the iconic mission
control.
Monochrome displays
talking to IBM mainframes.
No such thing as a
personal computer.
It wasn't even a glint
in anybody's eye.
These are for communications,
as in you hear people talking.
And by these buttons, you can
configure who you listen to
and who you talk to.
So the yellow lights,
which are dimmer,
are who you're listening to.
The flashing white light
is who you can talk to.
And then there are blue lights,
which could be either or.
These are hard key sets,
tactile feel-- pretty cool.
Audible click when you
hit one of those buttons.
And when I was a college
student at Houston,
these were the consoles we used.
From Apollo to the shuttle,
they hadn't upgraded yet.
So this was the
stuff I trained on.
Though I will say I
did not train on that,
and I have no idea
what those are.
And I've asked several
colleagues at Houston,
and nobody knows what those are.
So if any of you
guys know, tell me.
I'm going to do a closeup and
get into these displays later,
so I won't get into
that in detail.
Up here are what we call
the digital display drivers
or event lights.
Think of a plastic overlay
put in, and a bunch of lights
behind, and you
program these lights.
And they're just binary.
They're either on
or off, and you just
program them with
discrete values.
Very simple, yet they worked.
So I remember my first set of
displays in mission control.
Once you did these things,
you couldn't change them.
And I got very
clear instructions
the first time I did
this from my lead.
He said, I'm not going to watch
over you while you do this.
They have to be right.
If anything's wrong, after they
hang me, I'm going to kill you.
And that was the only-- so
anyway-- and the result of that
is, you put an
astronomical amount of time
into making sure these
things are right,
because you can't change them.
So my displays had no problems.
Everything worked fine.
But of all my status
lights, one of them-- one
I got my binaries
reversed, and I
had to spend this entire mission
staring at this light that
was on when it
should have been off.
And it drove me nuts.
But anyway, just
a personal story.
These are pneumatic tubes,
literally little P tubes.
You can put a piece of
paper or something in there
and send it from one
console to another.
And you're sitting
there on console,
and you hear this whoosh
and bang and the thud,
and these P tubes arrived.
And you open the door, and
you get your message out
of the P tube.
Those are used for
hard-copied information.
Hard copied-- can you
guys imagine that?
I will say that other things--
unofficial things, sometimes--
went through those P tubes.
But I won't say what.
Some of that may be online.
So if you pop up to
the newer consoles,
they don't look
that much different.
OK, so you're running
X Windows here,
and you got a lot more display
and application options.
You are running plasma touch
screens for your voice loops
instead of the
tactile hard clicks.
And to me, these were much
more flexible and easier
on your life between
flights, because you
didn't have to decide
exactly how to do
the hard coding before.
But these were much more
fun and easy to push and use
during flight.
So that was a trade off.
But the basic operations
mode hasn't changed much.
It's just that the
technology has been upgraded.
So just quickly-- people usually
ask what I do at the end,
so I throw it in here.
I was a summer intern here.
I was a college kid
on those consoles.
And that was just a
hell of a lot of fun.
So that was a couple weeks
after the first space shuttle.
First space shuttle,
imagine that.
That was incredible.
AUDIENCE: You look like
the guy from "War Games."
JAY TRIMBLE: Oh my god.
OK, I never thought of that.
And here-- this was at
Johnson Space Center-- here,
I moved to the Jet
Propulsion Laboratory,
but I was Lead Ops Director for
an earth remote sensing radar
that we flew on the shuttle,
about the size of a bus.
And all I can say is, it
was a fantastic experience.
We designed our Payload
Ops Control Center.
We did the hardware.
We did the software.
The radar was built at JPL.
We flew it twice on Endeavour,
and it was just a lot of fun.
So going back in
time here, because I
want to talk about display
technology and applications
and how we package
this stuff for users.
I want to give you
a little background
so you can understand the
mental model that we're
dealing with here.
And I understand this is
a little bit hard to read,
and I apologize for that.
I need a better scan.
This is how you
specify the display.
So this was Solar Max Repair,
the first satellite repair
mission.
We had George Nelson
flying out literally
in a Buck Rogers-style
backpack to rendezvous
with the satellite, bring that
satellite back to the shuttle,
put it in the payload bay.
And I'm this college kid
building displays for this,
so I thought this was
the coolest thing ever.
And we built the same
displays on the ground
as we built for the
crew, which we thought
was a great leap
forward at the time.
Nobody would think
twice about it then.
In fact, we had a meeting
with the crew-- Bob Crippen,
he was pilot from the
first shuttle, like I said,
George Nelson, who was flying
this manned maneuvering unit.
And I'm this college
student, and we're
meeting with the
crew, and I actually
decided I was going
to voice an opinion.
And I just I couldn't
quite get it out.
I remember all these
astronauts leaning in closer
to try and hear
what I was saying.
Anyway, I'm not so shy now.
But that was an awful
lot of fun at the time.
So on this grid, by hand I
would put in what I wanted--
the labels and the x's.
And I'm going to show you
what this display looked like.
And then I had another sheet
that would link a measurement
identification number to
a spot on the display.
Can you imagine?
This is called a
scratch pad line.
So the crew had this
keyboard, and we on the ground
could watch whatever they were
entering into the keyboard.
So we could see
what they were doing
if it was in the software.
If it was hard-coded
switch, we had
to view it through
telemetry and talk-backs.
But I just want to give you
guys an idea of how primitive
this was.
And it's the same type of
technology we flew to the moon
with.
And I have to say, it worked.
It worked, right?
We got to the moon.
We flew the space shuttle.
That is what that
display actually
looked like in hard copy.
And we had a little
button in mission control.
And if we wanted to take
a record of something,
we had a hard copy button.
And I think this thing
came through the P tube.
I'm trying to remember that.
Times zones, GMT, and
then mission elapsed time.
So think about it--
you're going to train
for a series of mission
events, but if you do those
to an absolute time
and you launch late,
the whole thing
goes out the window.
So mission elapsed time
starts at engine ignition
and goes from there.
It's a relative time.
And this is a display for the
Flight Support System, which
is when the satellite
was brought back in,
it was put in the Flight
Support System to be repaired.
Now, I know you guys are used
all these little touchscreens
from "Star Trek" and stuff.
And by the way,
according to what
I've read-- I wasn't
there-- those touchscreens
we're done because of
budget limitations.
Touchscreens seem to be
the direction we're headed.
There's a panel
from the shuttle.
Simple toggle displays
with mechanical talk-backs.
But it all worked.
Can we read this?
You guys can't read that.
Sorry about that.
I was trying to give you an
idea of how we did timelines.
Mission elapsed time,
key event, and then roles
for different-- mission control,
Payload Ops Control Center.
That was in Washington, DC.
They controlled the
satellite, and we
were responsible
for the shuttle.
So that's the old
mission control.
I want to talk a little
bit about evolution.
And a lot of folks say,
well, why change it all?
Because the current model works.
And I think that's a
legitimate question.
It does get hard to just keep
technology standing still,
though.
So maybe you guys will
have some perspectives
on that you can share with me
as we get towards the end here.
I will say that when you
get a group of people
who want to create change, you
will get a certain friction
from those who resist it.
I don't find that to
be unique to NASA.
And occasionally, I find
myself having more sympathy
for that group as I get an
upgrade to a piece of software
I use that I think
changes everything around
for no perceivable benefit.
So maybe I'm just getting
crotchety as we go.
I don't know.
Like I said, share a
perspective with me
on that when we get to
the Q&A part, or anytime.
I do think that software
built as applications
creates a set of walls.
So if I'm using Photoshop
or Painter, or any
of these other tools-- and
they're all good tools--
and I can't mix
and match my tools.
I really have to take
the whole package.
And we have the same issue
with our software or a word
processor.
I could be using
Google's stuff, or I
could be using Apple's
stuff, or Microsoft.
There's all kinds of choices
here, and they're all a package
set.
Duplication-- a few years ago,
I counted the drawing tools
on one of my older computers.
10 sets of drawing tools that
did pretty much the same thing.
And then, of course,
you get software bloat.
You just keep adding features.
In the commercial
world, it's very hard
to take a feature away.
Because any feature someone
has gotten used to-- you
can take some
obscure feature away,
and somebody somewhere is
going to have an absolute fit.
And it's the same thing here.
Who successfully
takes features away?
Apple does it, and
people make noise.
And they do it.
So it's very hard for us
to do that internally.
So open source-- I'm going to
come back to open source later.
Also, we've had a couple of
efforts here-- a desktop effort
called Mission Control
Technologies which
is on GitHub.
And I put the URL in there.
And it looks like in
blue against black,
you can't read it.
But if you search for NASA
MCT GitHub, you would find it.
And that's been
our first effort,
and it was done in Java.
And we are moving to a set
of web-based tools now called
Warp, and that's in the
queue to be open source.
And I hope that's out
there in the world
in a couple of months.
And I do believe that is
the direction we're headed.
I'll show the URLs
again at the end.
And of course, I would
love people's feedback.
So why do we open source stuff?
Because open source
does take some effort.
You have to go through
the legal approval
if you're going to have
any sort of success.
You have to support
the community.
You guys have more experience
with this than we do.
So why do it?
Well, there's a couple ideas.
One, for collaboration.
We used to go to somebody--
even internally, but certainly
externally-- with our
software, and say, hey, we've
got this cool software.
Why don't you use it?
And they'd say, OK,
can we download it?
And I would say, sure.
Let me get a legal agreement
together, our lawyers,
your lawyers.
And maybe in a couple of months,
you could try the software.
How do you think
that worked out?
You guessed it-- it didn't.
So open source, that
conversation is great.
Go to GitHub, you can
have it right now.
So it's the immediate
enabler for collaboration.
I think with ground system
technology-- this is just me--
we should share that.
Really, the focus
of space flight
is on the flight systems.
And we should be getting
these ground systems out
there so anybody can use them.
Just my opinion.
I would love to think that we
can build a community of people
open sourcing ground systems so
that's it's not novel anymore.
And there's always this chance.
Maybe we can put it out there,
innovation out to the outside,
and we will get something
that we had never thought of.
OK.
So think about what I
was showing you earlier.
There was no concept of
an application, a widget.
We were simply
looking at displays.
I don't think we cared
about the software.
I don't think we
thought about it.
We've evolved to applications.
I want to move us to
objects and compositions,
and I don't think people
will understand that.
And I'll show you some
pictures of what that means.
But anyway, depending
on-- everybody
has a different mental model.
To a flight controller, you're
just looking at displays.
And what are you doing when
you're doing Google Apps?
Are you looking at apps?
Are you looking at
objects within apps?
It really depends.
It depends on your mental model.
So if you get a software-ish
flight controller,
you can talk this language.
Otherwise, they're
not that interested.
Also, I think more and more--
we get into these sandboxes.
So in a mission,
I just want people
to be able to get to
their information.
That's what you want to do.
And as an analog, you
don't want to be there
on the mission saying,
wow, is it in Dropbox?
Is it in Google Drive?
Maybe it's in iCloud.
All these sandboxes
we're creating--
and there's reasons for
creating those sandboxes.
Some of it is security.
But I just find constantly
I'm having to scratch my head
and saying, wow, did I put
that in my encrypted image
on Google Drive?
Is it local on my desktop?
Imagine putting something
local on your desktop.
But people still do it.
So anyway, how we chunk
this stuff, how we get at
it is all a set of issues.
So let's see if I
can make this-- man,
you can't read that too well.
Let's try and make this
moderately comprehensible.
Here's the old stuff
that I show you.
And the mental
model is displays.
And those displays
are on channels.
So I have a DTE guide.
It was called a Digital
Television Equipment guide.
I think it had 73 channels.
And I have to look
at that, and I'm
going to go to this
little channel selector,
and I'm going to
move my little dials,
select a channel.
I've got three monitors.
I hit a button, I get a
hard click, and it appears.
Now, otherwise, next
model, applications--
do you notice anything
amidst these applications?
Do they look somewhat
heterogeneous?
I think they do.
Lack of consistency-- now,
that happens in industry, too,
right?
I know at Google a few
years ago versus now,
there's been a big drive
to create design unity,
bring things together, material
design, all this stuff.
And as a user, I'll
tell you that shows.
I can tell.
Things seem much
more unified now.
But when you're here, which
we were a few years ago,
that's an issue.
So the idea here
is to where we can
move into an objects and
composition model that does not
force you to think
about applications,
and allows you to think more
about what you are doing.
And of course, that's an ideal.
And it will work
in some instances,
and in other
instances, it won't.
But it is one direction
in which we're headed.
And I hope that makes sense.
OK.
History lesson for you guys.
So how many people have
heard of Xerox Star?
Wow, just a couple
of you guys, huh?
How about Open
Doc, Apple and IMB?
I know you guys
in the-- you know.
OK.
Interesting.
All right.
So if you go back to the history
of where all this stuff came
from, the Xerox Star was one
of the first commercial GUIs
I know you guys all know about
Xerox Park and the famous demos
and how the GUI came about.
But if you look
back to this, there
wasn't so much this
idea of applications.
There was this idea of objects--
inbox, outbox, documents,
printers.
Instead of applications, you
were interacting with objects.
You didn't have
this sense that I
was going to go to Google Drive
or Google Docs or Google Sheets
you were just
interacting with objects.
OpenDoc, the idea here
is you have a container,
and you put parts
into that container,
and each of those
parts has editors.
So instead of a word processor,
I have a word processing part
or a spreadsheet part,
and I can mix and match
and create various compositions.
I don't know that these things
failed for technical reasons,
and I'm not going to
try and analyze that.
That would be outside the
scope of what I'm saying here.
But there's some very
interesting ideas
that got left in the
cutting room floor
as we moved to the
application model
that we're all
pretty familiar with.
So in dealing with
information, we have models,
and we have views.
And we have different ways
of looking at the same thing.
So our idea, which
I'm going to show you,
is to provide a
unified environment.
But to do that,
I'm just giving you
an example of my calendar,
my ever-so exciting calendar.
That is on my Mac.
Desktop application, Apple's
Calendar application.
Does that look familiar?
That's Google.
It's the same info, but
it looks very different.
Also the same info on my iPhone.
Also on my iPhone, but
a different application.
And my point is, I'm basically
doing Model View Controller,
MVC, by using different
applications to connect
to my model.
And I want to see these
things in different ways.
And I'm literally
using a different app
to get my different views.
And I'm not saying
that's a bad thing.
It's one way to do it
in a commercial market.
Does that look
familiar to you guys?
So here, at least for me,
when I'm in Google Drive,
I feel like I'm going
to find my stuff.
I'm going to find my document,
or my spreadsheet, or my image.
I'm not thinking applications.
I'm really thinking
of what I want to do.
Whereas here, this is
Google Docs on the iPad.
There, I'm only going to see
one view of my documents,
and I'm really starting
with the application first.
So where do I go?
Do I go to the application,
or do I go to the data?
And the answer is, we're
going to be able to do both.
There's no one right
answer to this, of course.
So our approach-- and
some of this stuff
may look-- you can see where
we got some of this inspiration
from.
It might look
moderately familiar.
But we just put all our
objects in one environment.
And this is new.
This is the stuff that's going
to be open source shortly.
It's our web-based version
of mission control, just
the visualization.
I don't mean to imply it's
all of mission control.
It's a slice of it.
We had a lot of discussion
about which browser to use,
and our answer to that is that
we will develop and test it
in Chrome.
We are not doing
anything to preclude
it running in
other browsers yet.
There's discussion as to whether
to use Chrome specific things.
But so far, we do all our
testing and all our development
in Chrome.
And I'll leave it at that.
So all your stuff is in here.
There's no sense of
different applications.
I find something, I look
at it, and I look at it
through different views.
That's my model view controller.
So this is just simply apply.
But the point I want
to get across here
is everything is in one place.
So these are the
ideas-- no applications.
You've got objects
and compositions.
I can look at the same thing
in many different ways,
in many different places.
And in a second, I'm going
to tell you about one
of the reasons why
I want to do that.
So that is the same information.
You're just looking at
it in different views.
You've just got a
little pull-down here,
and I could look at the same
thing in different ways.
So why do I give a hoot?
Here's a mission example.
This is for scientists.
And I'm sorry.
When I took these
pictures, I really
never intended these
to be closeups.
These are actually
pictures from a room,
and I just grabbed them.
But the point is,
that's a PowerPoint
representation of a timeline.
That's actually a
sequential set of events,
as is that, for
scientists, for engineers.
But the point is,
I want to see all
these things in different ways.
And what you get in a mission
standpoint potentially
is disconnect.
I've been in rooms
where I've heard, say,
a power number or
a power constraint,
and actually people had
given different numbers
in two different rooms.
We don't want that.
We want everything
to be a display
of the same underlying data.
Examples here.
Once again, I
don't know how much
you guys want to get
into software or mission
control or open source.
I don't mind you guys steering
me in one direction or another.
This, when you demo it live,
is actually pretty cool.
So that's a notebook.
Unremarkable.
I'm sitting at a console,
and I'm saying, OK,
at mission elapse,
time such and such,
the following thing happened.
And I'm writing my notes,
or I'm typing my notes.
So what this does for you is
it time stamps it for you.
You put your notes in.
And even more cool, I
can embed the live data
into the notebook, because
I've got this composition
model instead of an
application model.
I just take my data and I
embed it in the notebook.
And that is a huge
advantage instead
of referencing something
or hyperlinking something.
I've just got the
actual data there.
Even more cool, I can take
this notebook and say,
you know what?
I want to see my notebook
at a timeline view.
And there's my timeline view.
And then I'm going to put
my plotted data next to it.
Now I can start doing
all kinds of cool things,
just because I have models,
views, and compositions.
And I will admit
this is not software
I would give to my mother.
But for what we do,
it's good stuff.
OK.
And here, I'm just trying to
show more of the data types.
There's the timeline
you saw earlier,
another timeline, orbits,
plotted telemetry-- my point
being that we can put
all this stuff together.
It's very hard to design
this stuff ahead of time
and get it right.
What we find is, we
sit down and we say,
here's what we think we need.
And we build it, and
we start simulations,
and those simulations
typically start about a year
before launch.
And it's in
simulations where you
learn what you
really want to do.
What would you guys do?
You might do a "Wizard
of Ox" walk-through,
or you might do a
paper prototype.
And there's a number
of things you can do.
But in this domain,
it's very hard
until we start doing simulations
to realize what we really want.
So this kind of flexibility
in design is quite helpful.
AUDIENCE: Is there a timeline
[INAUDIBLE] you're showing,
or that's just driven
off of the notebook
that you've created after
the fact or in real time?
JAY TRIMBLE: Create the
notebook in real time.
AUDIENCE: And then
do you ever-- do
you have timeline views
that you create beforehand?
JAY TRIMBLE: Oh, absolutely.
Yeah.
Now, the ideal-- and we
haven't done this yet,
but we're working towards
it in the web version-- is
to be able to compare the
predicted to the actuals
and overlay all this stuff.
We're not there yet,
but that's the hope.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] towards
the direction where you can
[INAUDIBLE] during the mission?
JAY TRIMBLE: So, very
interesting question.
Technically, yes, that
would be easy to do.
Operationally, you would
need a set of constraints
to keep that under control.
Because you are training
to a particular layout
and a particular composition.
And I would be very careful
about how I allow changes
during a mission.
I don't think from a
mission ops perspective--
me personally creating
a new composition, fine.
Changing an existing composition
that I had worked to,
I would be a little
bit concerned about.
Think about flying
in an airplane.
You wouldn't want the
pilots rearranging things.
I wouldn't.
So quickly, I'm going
to use an example.
This is a mission in
the early design phase.
It's called Resource Prospector.
Got that nice short,
one-way light time.
Lunar Rover to explore for
volatiles at the poles.
And this the vision of
how to put this together.
I drew this out
about a week ago.
And I said, my god,
it looks like iGoogle.
Are we just doing widgets here?
And you guys stopped iGoogle.
And then I started
asking myself,
what's the difference between
this and a set of widgets?
Well, interesting question.
To me, in my mind,
these are not widgets.
This is the actual procedure
viewer and the procedure
editor, and those
are the timelines.
But when you put them
together and compose them
into an integrated display, they
do look somewhat like widgets.
So I'll put that out there.
And this is the first demo-able
prototype of that display.
It doesn't have everything.
Some of it's real,
some of it's not.
That's just a picture.
That's from another piece
of software called XGDS.
But this is all in our software
called WARP-- Web Applications
for Resource Prospector, so
named by our lead developer,
Victor Wolfgen, who's sitting
in the back of the room.
So of course, we are going
to have to drive the Rover.
And each one of
these components is
called WARP-- WARP
Viewer, WARP Image.
So of course we will
have WARP Drive.
I think we named it WARP
before we figured out
we were going to
have WARP drive.
But this shows the
basic concepts.
I've got a timeline.
I've got all these
mixed data types.
And I can view the same
data in different ways.
And I can put that all
together into a composition.
And so we had done that
on the desktop in Java,
and now we're doing
it on the web,
and we're pretty
excited about that.
And of course, we will try to
take that to the tablet next,
and then to the phone.
So here's a little bit of
a closeup of the timeline.
You can see what
we're doing here.
We're using this for design.
So we're mapping out the
traverses we want to do,
and then we just
map power and data.
And then we go back
and say, OK, we
have a certain allocation
for power and data.
Can we do it within
what we have?
Do we try and push the design of
the system to have more power?
And we can answer questions
like, for a certain size
battery on the Rover,
what kind of a mission
can we get out of it?
So we're using that timeline
for design at this point.
And you can see up here,
you've got the pull-downs.
We've got an Edit mode here.
And everything is over
here on that Create button.
You guys know this
story, because you've
got similar stuff.
Plots, I think I've
already shown that,
so I'm not going to
spend much time there
as I'm getting towards my
40-minute time limit here.
This is the notebook, the same
idea as the notebook you saw,
except web based.
I get timestamps.
I get my notes.
And I get to embed
information in this.
So just a couple
more slides here.
So as I said--
AUDIENCE: Do you have a raw
[INAUDIBLE] number view?
JAY TRIMBLE: Well,
in this software--
you mean raw as in pulse
code modulation counts,
for example, the
straight data value?
Do we have that?
Victor is nodding his head
yes so I guess we have that.
Most people-- so here, what
people want to see varies.
If you have a long program,
you have flight controllers
who are really
thinking operationally
versus the guys who
built it who want
to see maybe things
in more detail.
OK.
So this, as I
said, is on GitHub.
I hope you guys can read that.
That's the Java desktop version.
I wish I could sit
here and tell you
that the web version
is open source.
I think it's very close, but
it's not quite there yet.
I believe that's all I have.
This is our info site.
If you check back
in a couple months,
you might find the web version.
AUDIENCE: Since
it's browser based,
any openness to
potentially allowing
people to create their own
composition on view-only data
to follow a Mars
mission from the public?
JAY TRIMBLE: I would love it
if stuff like that happened.
And our goal is to get
this stuff out there.
It's on GitHub.
And say, you can do
anything you want with this.
The key to that would
be that we would
have to make some of
that data available,
which is something we
will definitely explore.
And then to take it
back-- so anybody
can put anything on GitHub
once we've got it out there.
So that would be
completely unrestricted.
My hope is also that there
will be brilliant ideas, things
we had never thought of that
we can take back and actually
use for missions.
And I see little
inklings of that.
We've had contributors
for our Java version.
Some of them have just
been our own folks
that have left
and kept using it.
But then a guy pops up from
France, and all of a sudden,
he's writing code.
If we're going to use it
in a NASA distribution,
we have to do the paperwork
and get permission
from the developer to do that.
But folks can put anything
they want out on GitHub.
And yeah, I'm hoping that
we get a web version out
there that it stimulates a bit
of an open source community
and people become interested.
AUDIENCE: You said that
you run these simulations
six months ahead of time.
JAY TRIMBLE: Usually
about a year.
AUDIENCE: So you have
some idea of what
the process of the mission
is going to be like,
and what the data coming
in from your sensors
is going to be like at
different stages of the mission.
And you're watching
that, and then you're
making decisions
based on when you
see the data get to a
certain point, right?
JAY TRIMBLE: Correct.
AUDIENCE: You're like, I'm
deciding at this moment,
I'm going to turn something on.
Is there a temptation
to automate that?
Like, when I see the
sensors in this state,
I want to automatically
make this decision
that I've pre-verified?
JAY TRIMBLE: I will
give you one example,
because it came up recently.
For the Moon Rover,
the question was asked,
do we want to be able to
automate the prospecting
decisions?
So we are driving, we are
with the spectrometers
looking for water.
Depending on that
data, do we want
to be able to
automate the decision?
And my answer to this is--
which validated with the science
team-- we won't know in the
short duration of our mission
how to interpret that data
well enough to automate it.
If we had a mission
that was going
to go for six months or a
year, I would say absolutely.
AUDIENCE: So once you verify
what your decisions are
on the expected
pathway, it seems
like you've already
automated it.
But you're just
waiting on a human
to actually push the button?
JAY TRIMBLE: Yeah.
We haven't done much on it now.
I can't speak for all of NASA.
I can only speak for the
little slice that I know.
I haven't seen a
lot of automation.
I have heard some discussion.
I think with system values,
that might be an easier thing
to do than with science
data interpretation,
and what I was talking about
was science data interpretation.
You have certain
limits for a subsystem,
and you know how
that's going to behave.
But think of the example I
gave you earlier for that Abort
To Orbit for the space shuttle.
I just don't think
anybody would have--
I don't think we're there yet
for automating something that
complicated where
human life is at risk.
And the answer is, these
conversations will be ongoing.
AUDIENCE: Could you
maybe speak to the limits
of some of these
values coming in
and how it displays to the
screen and the operator's
views?
JAY TRIMBLE: So
I'm going to start
with those old
monochrome displays.
You had a little arrow, and it
was called out of limits high,
out of limits low.
And then you had another
indication for off scale,
meaning it was out of
the scale of the sensor.
And we used to use
that in the office.
If somebody was nuts, we'd
say they're off scale.
But now with all the
flexibility we have,
you can design green,
yellow, red, really any kind
of indication that
you want as long
as you know what that means.
But you have for
any subsystem an
acceptable-- like
for your computer,
you have an
operational temperature
range for your computer.
You have a storage
temperature range.
It's the same idea.
And it's just a matter
of how to indicate that
on a display and some sense of
what you will do that you've
discussed ahead of
time if something's not
what you expect.
AUDIENCE: So this is mission
control, not flight drivers,
obviously.
But I imagine there's still
some sort of risk involved
in opening this
up to open source.
If something is bad--
we've all had experiences,
I think, with open
source software
where something was not
done well or correctly,
and this can
potentially be a risk.
So I wonder what kind
of further process
there is to mitigate that risk.
JAY TRIMBLE: I've been asked
that question internally a lot.
And the answer is, right now,
it's been mostly one way.
It's been us putting
stuff out into the world.
There's been very
little input path back.
Most of the input
path back has been
from people who've left us and
kept working on that software.
So it's been a very
tightly bounded problem.
Then we've had just a
couple of other people
who've made inputs, but we
haven't incorporated that.
So I think the answer
is, so far, we've
been able to duck that question.
If this were to
actually take off,
then we'd have to have a process
for not only what you said,
but deciding which design
we like, how much of this
can we take.
And I hope we are in
the position of having
to deal with that, but
we really haven't yet.
I'll probably be calling
Chris and asking him
how to handle that
when the time comes.
And I thank you for
volunteering, Chris,
to help with that.
CHRIS DIBONA: That's
what I'm here for.
AUDIENCE: The open
source part of this,
is it just the front end UI, or
is there a back-end component
to this?
JAY TRIMBLE: So far, it
is the front-end stuff.
And open sourcing these
things just takes a while.
We will get more out
there, and my hope
is to get everything out there.
But right now, it's all the
front-end visualization stuff.
When you mention
open source, there's
a lot of teams who would like
to open source their stuff.
AUDIENCE: What feeds
it right now currently?
Where's the bridge?
JAY TRIMBLE: Where are
we getting our data?
AUDIENCE: If you were to pick
this up as an open source,
how would you feed it?
JAY TRIMBLE: I'm going to
let Victor handle that one,
since it's why he's here.
And he wrote some of
these data adapters.
VICTOR WOLFGEN:
Generally speaking,
the front end is plug-in based.
So a category of plug-in you
can introduce to the front end,
and that's the code
that runs on the browser
is a connector to
a data back-end.
So the expectation would just
be that whatever the data source
it has, or whatever data
source you're integrating with,
you either have or create
some kind of web service
to expose that data, and then
present that data internally
in the format that the
application understands.
AUDIENCE: So the move to
a purely web-based thing,
you gain a lot of
flexibility, but you
lose some of the
tactile physical stuff.
When you're talking about
pressing the buttons for who
to talk to, I can imagine
sometimes on a web interface,
if you're using a
mouse or a touchscreen,
you might mis-click
on something.
And it's a lot easier
to click on something
incorrectly than to
press a button that
has some resistance incorrectly.
So do you worry
about or do you have
plans for breaking
some of the stuff
into more physical,
tactile feedback?
Is that an issue
that you encounter?
JAY TRIMBLE: At the moment, we
have a whole separate system
for the voice loops.
So going to a
web-based system, we're
really taking things that have
moved to desktop applications
already and just putting them
into web-based applications.
We're not doing things
like the voice loops.
And we lost that tactile
feedback years ago we
moved from those
hard click displays
to the touch screen displays.
So I think people
are used to that.
But the voice loops are a
separate system right now.
AUDIENCE: You talked
about the heritage
coming from mission control.
I'm wondering if there
are other domains where
you think the open source
project might be useful,
and if you've drawn
inspiration from other domains
into this-- so Bloomberg
terminals or logs, analyses,
interfaces, other kinds
of real time things.
Or do you think that this
is going to always live
in a world of mission control,
and maybe the ESA wants it?
JAY TRIMBLE: Oh, I
think the more we
can interact with the
world and draw inspirations
like what you're talking
about, the better off we are.
So do we look at these things?
Yes.
Do we look at them as
much as I'd like to?
Probably not.
But we definitely look
at financial plotting
applications, for
example, to compare them
to what we're doing.
I think the data
rates-- and I don't
know much about financial
plotting applications--
but especially
during launch prep,
we're blasting pretty
high data rates.
And I don't know
that financials need
to be updated multiple
times a second,
but we certainly do
look at those things.
And it is my hope that
through open source,
we can start to get some of
that two-way conversation.
I hope that people will find our
things useful in other domains
and that we will cross
pollinate with other domains.
That's part of the goal.
We're just in the very, very
early stages of it right now.
So the question was, is there
a command interface for this.
And the answer is
not yet, because it
is the single most
sensitive thing that we do.
If people are so sensitive
about their commanding,
I think the idea
in open source is
we would let them
build their own.
We may, for some of
our own missions,
build a command interface, or
we may use an existing one.
But it will be the
last thing we do,
because of the
sensitivity of it.
CHRIS DIBONA: Well, thank
you so much for coming.
It's really great to have you.
[APPLAUSE]